Welcome to Women's History Month,
where if you are a woman who has had a not so amazing experience
with a certain popular prescription drug,
The Washington Post is here to tell you to be quiet about it.
This is one of those all too common instances
where we see a major media company
pretending to be a champion for women,
celebrating women's history with crossword puzzles
and amplifying women's voices,
talking about how important we are.
The truth is that these kinds of companies and publications
only care about celebrating and amplifying the voices
of certain women.
If you are a woman who steps out of line for a single second,
if you even dare to share a personal experience
that they find personally or politically inconvenient,
they demand you shut up.
So if you go and read the article,
you'll find a couple instances of the Washington Post
contacting different social media platforms
and pressuring them
into removing the videos of certain women sharing their experiences
again with this prescription drug.
The Washington Post could have done a lot with this article,
especially during,
you know, Women's Month.
They could have asked more women about their personal experiences.
They could have asked more doctors about their experiences.
They could have compared studies,
like, many studies.
They could have dug really deep into the facts about this entire thing.
But instead,
they kind of decided to take the more easy, political way and,
you know, just try and just Try and silence the conversation.
So please, Washington Post,
spare us with all the pro woman
amplifying women's voices kind of cliches.
Don't pretend to celebrate us on one hand
while actively trying to silence us on the other.